I'm a proud lifelong nerd,
and I have a PhD in chemistry
and chemical biology to prove it,
which is why I never thought
I'd be that guy standing up here,
talking about my love affair with fashion.
(Laughter)
And there's someone else in my life
who's equally shocked
by this turn of events,
and that's my wonderful wife,
who literally has a degree in fashion.
(Laughter)
But here I am, standing
with these two wallets.
One of these is made out of leather,
one of these is made out of mushrooms.
And I'm not going to tell you
which one is which.
The average consumer
can't tell you the difference --
kind of the whole point.
Because even if you hate fashion,
you've got an entire room
in your house devoted to it.
It's called your closet.
And your closet is full
of all kinds of materials --
cotton, leather, nylon, polyester --
that list goes on and on.
And those materials matter,
because those materials are the reason
fashion is in the midst
of a sustainability crisis.
This is an industry that makes
100 billion plus items per year.
When I started my journey, I thought
this was going to be a really easy answer.
We just consume less,
we have fewer, better things.
But in the last decade,
I've come to believe
that ignores fundamental realities
of both fashion and human nature.
You see, fashion is not purely functional.
It's about confidence,
creativity, self-expression.
It's a pure reflection
of our innate desire, as humans,
to always want more.
And it satisfies our insatiable appetites
to discover, buy, collect, show off.
In truth, fashion
is intrinsic to who we are.
There is a piece of good news, though.
We can make fashion sustainable,
and we're going to do it with science,
and we're going to do it
not by changing the humans,
but by changing
those materials themselves.
And lucky for us,
the answers to all of fashion's
materials problems
are available today, out there in nature,
and it's our job, as scientists,
to go find the best inventions
from nature's four-billion-year
catalog of greatest hits
and bring them to the world of design.
So I started a PhD,
and I actually fell in love
with one of these materials from nature.
And it's this -- it's spider silk.
It's this fine, elegant, tough fiber
that spiders make.
You've probably seen
a Spider-Man movie, you know.
You may have wanted to make
Peter Parker's web slinger.
It's OK -- I did, too; it's badass.
I wanted to recreate
that material in a lab,
so I started a company,
and we did just that.
And the very first product
we made was this:
a tie.
I took the very first tie,
and I sent it to Stan Lee himself,
cocreator of Spider-Man,
idol to nerds around the planet,
all-around amazing human.
And he loved it.
He actually cold-called my phone
from a blocked number,
and we geeked out over the technology.
And back in those days,
almost nobody was working
on sustainable materials in fashion.
So I excitedly ran off to go talk
to designers and fashion executives.
And they thought this was fine, cool,
but they couldn't shut up
about their problem with leather.
And for really good reason.
Leather is one of the most pivotal
materials in the fashion world.
In 2020 alone, the five biggest
European luxury houses
sold over 50 billion dollars
of leather goods.
And the challenge with leather
is that today, it's inextricably
linked to raising cows,
and not just a few -- like, lots of cows.
And cows, at the global scale,
are terrible for our environmental future.
And so I left this conversation thinking,
"OK, what makes leather leather?"
And the truth is,
nobody loves leather
because it comes from a cow.
We love it because it's strong,
it's soft, it's beautiful.
It plays from the runway in Paris
to a rodeo in Texas.
So if we can take cows
out of the equation,
what's the thing we have to replicate
to make a great material like leather?
And the answer is microstructure.
So this is a microscope image
of the collagen in cowhide.
And it looks like a mess,
it's just this jumble of fibers
mixed together.
At its essence, that structure
is why leather is both pliable and strong.
Now, contrast that to your closet.
All those materials
are what we call knits or wovens.
They look like this under a microscope.
Essentially, you take a single thread,
and you loop it around itself,
or you crisscross it over itself,
and you make a fabric.
If we want to make a new material
with the same amazing
properties as leather,
we need to go out
and find a natural material
with the same microstructure
as the collagen in cowhide.
Now, my brain gets going with this,
and I think, "OK, we can grow skin,
we can grow pure collagen,
we can use plant fibers ..."
Those all fail.
Quality, cost or scalability reasons
tank those ideas.
And that's what brought me
to the world of fungi.
I'm going to assume you all know
what mushrooms are.
I'm going to show you some mushrooms
on the side of a dead tree.
And I'm much more interested
in what's happening
just beneath the surface.
Inside that tree are millions
of stringy little strands
that are called mycelium,
that are eating away at it.
They look like this.
So you see those white fibrous roots
underneath the mushroom --
those are mycelium.
They’re these long branch networks.
And what they're doing is eating
dead stuff in the soil
and releasing nutrients to the mushroom
and to the ecosystem around it.
And so now, I'm going
to show you side by side.
Collagen on the left,
mycelium on the right.
We're looking at microstructure;
I'm saving you six years of getting a PhD.
(Laughter)
We're on to something here.
But to pull this off,
we need to do this
at the scale of fashion.
We need a lot of mycelium.
Not a lab, but a factory.
So that's exactly what we did.
So here, what you're seeing
is our first factory,
and you're seeing rows and rows
of pure mycelium
growing in these trays.
And those mycelium
are eating leftover sawdust,
so they're doing what fungi
do best in nature --
they eat something nobody wants,
and they turn it into something useful.
And instead of growing into the soil,
these mycelium are growing up
in these big puffy clouds
that we can easily harvest.
And this is where science
has to meet design.
We take that material
and turn it into something leatherlike.
It has to be beautiful,
has to be functional.
And designers need to be able
to easily incorporate it
into the world of fashion products.
The first prototypes
were none of those things.
But after many thousands of iterations,
we have a material, and we call it Mylo.
And Mylo does everything
we set out for it.
It's beautiful, it's functional,
but most importantly, it's sustainable.
So when you grow mushrooms,
it takes about a little under one
square meter of land
to grow one kilogram of mushrooms.
Contrast that to cows --
takes about 97 square meters of land
to grow one kilogram of cow.
And when we're growing Mylo,
we're doing this in high-density
vertical agriculture,
and we power it with 100 percent
renewable energy.
And this is technology.
We're constantly getting better.
Contrast that to the cow.
It's about as good as it's going to get,
and the cows really don't like it
when you stack them up
in high-density vertical agriculture.
And so the question remains:
How are we going to distribute
this material at global scale
to meet the moment?
I have bad news for you here.
Historically, it takes decades
for a new material to reach
global-scale adoption.
Take spandex, that stretchy fiber.
It's in your blue jeans, your yoga pants.
Makes your butt look amazing.
That material was invented in the 1950s,
and it wasn't until the athleisure
megatrend 50 years later
that it was truly everywhere
on this planet.
And thank you, climate change --
we humans don't have 50 years to wait.
We need to solve this problem.
We need new materials,
and we need them now.
And this is where fashion
can be transformational.
So I went out and constructed
what we call the Mylo Consortium.
These are fashion brands you know.
Stella McCartney, lululemon,
Kering and Adidas.
Normally, fashion brands are renowned
for their competitive nature
and their desire for exclusivity.
But I was able to convince these brands
that no one group
can solve this problem alone.
And to meet this moment,
it was time to act in collaboration
instead of competition.
We did just that.
With the idea that we're going to solve
this really big problem really fast.
And here's a taste
of how they're supporting Mylo.
Lululemon wove Mylo
into yoga and wellness accessories.
Celebrity environmentalist Paris Jackson
modeled Mylo in this fashion editorial.
Adidas redesigned the Stan Smith --
it's their most iconic style --
with Mylo.
And Stella McCartney designed
the Frayme Mylo handbag,
and debuted it on the Paris runway.
And that little black handbag
that you see right there,
that's now part of Stella's
commercial collection.
And what that means
is that this is not some far-off idea
that's a dream that may one day be real.
Mylo's commercially viable today.
We sell it for 30 dollars a square foot.
It's about the price
of premium calf leather.
And this -- this is the tipping point.
This is the first tangible proof
that the future of fashion
can and will be made
with sustainable materials.
And this is our road map.
We went looking to nature
for a better alternative to leather,
and we found that mycelium.
It was hiding in plain sight.
And this story, Mylo's story,
is just one small example
in a much broader movement.
It's the one I know.
But in the last few years,
countless scientists have joined us
in this journey of a sustainable
materials revolution.
And in the coming years,
I think we're going to see
amazing advances
that replace all the harmful
materials in your closet,
in your home and your car.
And my hope is that,
by sharing this journey with Mylo,
it can act as a blueprint
that these others can follow
to more quickly improve
this world for all of us.
Because in my heart,
I'm still that nerd from the beginning,
and I want to know what else
is hiding out there in nature.
I want to know what's the number-one spot
on the best-of playlist
from four billion years of evolution.
And the incredible part of all this
is that fashion undoubtedly compounded
our sustainability crisis.
But fashion has a golden opportunity
to lead the charge,
to live with nature,
instead of against it.
And now, and in the future,
fashion's not just
about making yourself beautiful.
It's also about making this planet
beautiful and livable for generations.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)